[Music]  two deadly shootings within minutes of  each other keeping metro police very  busy this afternoon  the first happened at a neighborhood  near oaky and eastern just before 10  this morning police tell us when they  arrived to the scene they found  the victim a white man in his 30's dead  what we have learned is that there was  an altercation between him  and another male inside the residence  that male  fired at least one round striking and  killing the victim  the suspect then fled in a vehicle which  we are still attempting to locate  well he says the only information they  have on the suspect's car is that it's a  white nissan altima if you know anything  about this case you're  asked to please call crime stoppers that  number right there on your screen  702-385-5555